do you remember Jessica for time before
dating apps honestly no people would
just place adverts essentially in the
local newspaper if they were looking for
perhaps a mistress or a friend or a or a
lover and these were called The Lonely
Hearts adverts let me tell you this
story
of the Lonely Hearts Killers we'll go
right back to 1949. okay Albany New York
so it's January 1st and we have a 66
year old called Janet Faye nice right
and she's ready to bring in the New Year
she's going to meet her new flame man
new right 66 yeah and he goes by the
name of Charles Martin so she Janet is a
widow right and she's very very
religious she's a devout Catholic she's
a very strong pillar in her community
she's at church every Sunday loved by
her neighbors she is a great woman meets
up with Charles her new flame uh because
he answers her Lonely Hearts advert he
has claimed to be a like like-minded
with her religious belief so they're on
the same wavelength when it comes to
religion and he was a very successful
businessman and he was really keen on
her and I think that was very appealing
she was like he seems like a lovely man
right he came from a really nice family
right what is not attractive about that
you know absolutely nothing except he
was also very particularly close with
his sister okay right Martha that's not
a bad thing no so when they met up to
keep Janet from being a bit too you know
freaked out he bought Martha with him to
put her at ease a little bit and they
stay with Janet in New York for a couple
of days and after a few days he pops the
question he proposes and she's like yes
thank God please
so they're smitting with each other but
Janet's not so much smitten with Martha
because obviously a bit of a third wheel
um exactly and Martha's also been quite
cold and unresponsive and uncomfortable
and protective of her brother like she's
not being nice to Janet at all which is
a bit uncomfortable situation I would
argue
um so around
two weeks later
Janet's stepdaughter she's called Mary
Spencer
they were very close she gets a message
from Janet she receives a letter Janet's
letter uh was kind of insinuating that
she intended to move like hundreds of
miles away to go to Florida with Charles
and had given Mary her stepsister her
stepdaughter
um kind of instructions on how to pack
up all of Janet's stuff and move it to a
different apartment it was all a bit
suspicious I think Mary was a bit
suspicious okay she was like this is
weird Janet wouldn't really say this
kind of stuff yeah but what was most
suspicious is that in the letter it was
typed like it was on a typewriter it
wasn't handwritten so number one Mary
didn't even think that Janet had owned a
typewriter so that was kind of red flag
number one okay yeah and
didn't even know how to use one she
would only ever send handwritten letters
to Mary big red flag so Mary's like okay
something's wrong so after Janet so what
happened after Janet had said yes to
Charlie's proposal he was like pushing
her to get that wedding going he was
like let's get married let's go this
meant moving house like a few hours
outside of Albany to his apartment in
Long Island and he also convinced her to
write a series of checks that came up to
about four thousand dollars okay in that
time that would have been probably about
45 000 pounds now oh dollars forty five
thousand dollars now that's a lot of
money she goes even more concerned and
very confused by the fact that Charles
isn't gonna sleep
so she goes I'm gonna seduce him so
pretty directly in the living room
she lies on the sofa just naked just
waiting for him to come in
expecting that he will enter the door
but before he finds her
guess who walks in and finds her I think
it's uh his sister it is yeah so
Charles's sister Martha walks in Martha
went berserk she was berating Janet she
was having a go at her it was like
obviously Janet's completely embarrassed
and Janet told Martha that as soon as
her and Charles were going to be married
Martha would be kicked out they're not
going to live with her anymore good
stand your ground yeah yeah good good as
you should I like that that's what I say
so Martha filled with jealous rage picks
up a hammer batters Janna over the head
with it
okay
doesn't kill her oh just repeatedly over
the head that makes it almost worse
doesn't it just Charles comes in
sees what was ensued uh-huh gets a scarf
ties it around Janet's neck oh and
actually uses that Hannah as a
tourniquet and kills Janet so Janet's
now dead because she's been strangled
with the scarf that's not how I was
hoping that was going to go so they
cleaned up the scene yeah and they just
let Janet's body stay where it was until
the next morning they put it in a
suitcase and then took it to another
rented apartment in Queens
where they then buried it under cement
in the basement it was then that Charles
wrote letters on a typewriter to Janet's
family and friends as part of the
cover-up so he wrote the letter that
Mary had received from Janet it's
starting to add up that Mary was a bit
confused by
so stay with me we're going to jump 100
miles west okay to Michigan why well let
me tell you we're going to go to a town
called Grand Rapids where there lived a
lovely Delphine Downing so Delphine
Downing was a widow she was 28 so much
younger than Janet uh and she her
husband had died and she had a
two-year-old daughter called rainelle
sure lovely lovely little rainelle uh
and she got to the point where she
wanted to build a secure life for
herself and her daughter and start a new
family so this is January 1949. as in
the same January the same January the
same month so around this time Delphine
Delphine Downing invites a man a love
interest to come and stay with her at
her house that she'd met over the
Christmas period hmm he's a successful
businessman that's what he says he is
okay and so you know he's looking for
love and he's drawn to Delphine
do you want to guess what the guy's name
is oh I know what his name is is it
Charles it's Charles Martin so we can
imagine that this is in the same month
that he was talking to Janet so the
issue is socially contextually in 1940s
in a small little town in America an
unmarried woman who had not long been
widowed uh to host a gentleman cooler
out of wedlock prying eyes especially in
the suburb that she lived in like people
would be wondering what's going on
people sticking their noses and stuff
yeah yeah and in some cases annoying in
some cases maybe that's what you want
sure but luckily for everyone involved
it was okay because Charles bless his
heart bought lovely old Martha with him
his sister yeah so at the end of
February
the neighbors they're a bit suspicious
because people hadn't seen Delphine it's
the end of February so people hadn't
seen her all right now for a while and
they weren't really sure why Martha and
Charles were still at the house okay do
you know what I mean something seemed a
bit funny something seemed a bit off so
a neighbor of Delphine calls the police
so they arrive at delphine's door
they knock and guess who answers Charles
and Martha and Martha and Martha always
our Martha brother and sister Delphine
nowhere to be seen no one can find her
so they're questioned and Charles and
Martha come up with a story that
Delphine and rainelle were in Detroit
like visiting friends they it was just
like weird and that they were watching
the house it was like a weird made-up
story but the sheriffs who were
interviewing them had noticed bags in
the hallway as if someone was about to
arrive or someone was about to leave so
they stormed the house they raid the
house right they're
they're like in the house they get to
the basement what happens in the
basement
they notice a patch of cement on the
floor yeah and we know what happens with
cement yeah in these people's lives it
wasn't just ordinary cement it was wet
cement right it had just been recently
put down yeah like fresh wet cement so
they start digging in the wet cement and
they realize it's a shallow grape
of two dead bodies it's not great
Delphine and right now so the details
from this case we know came from Charles
Martin himself
um
or should I say
oh
should I say Raymond Fernando oh my God
there's a whole other personality right
there's a whole other that was his real
name all along so Raymond Raymond
Raymond Fernandez that was his real name
and you know the biggest plot twist of
them all Martha it's not his sister yeah
he's not his sister yeah
yeah they're like married aren't they or
something she was in fact his girlfriend
so they were con artists essentially
right so initially they were just going
around the country targeting like really
lonely often widowed um women at first
it was just for the money okay but then
the unplanned death of Janet Faye so it
was spontaneous what happened that
murder was not planned in the slightest
so once he was caught Raymond or Charles
Martin but Raymond you confessed to
literally everything and I'll explain
his confession so according to that
Delphine was rattled one night she was a
bit spooked because she had accidentally
walked in on him in the bathroom to find
out lo and behold he was bald what I
know he was wearing a toupee and
she began to get cold feet yeah because
she was like what else are you lying to
me about like this is so this is such a
betrayal of you so at this point
she also had concerns that she might be
pregnant with his baby that as a recent
video would have been a really big
Scandal so that was something she wanted
to avoid and she had confided and Martha
about this so Martha gave Delphine a
handful of pills and claimed that they
would work as abortion pills however
those pills were sleeping pills so
Delphine collapses after overdosing
reynell her daughter's in the room and
starts crying because she's seen her mum
passing out that's horrifying and really
traumatic so she starts crying Martha
cannot deal with it so she grabs the
toddler around the neck and begins to
strangle her
and Raymond has to pull her off however
Raymond notices that Martha has left
like Marx on raynell's neck and it's
furious with Martha because if Delphine
wakes up
she'll call the police because you know
her daughter's now got you know
strangled marks on it so Raymond takes a
pistol
that Delphine kept in the house
shoots Delphine between the eyes
immediately killing her yeah this then
because raynell is still in the room
right now it's a two-year-old yeah yeah
has just seen her mother been
slaughtered in front of her sure and
she's just seen her mother die
and she starts to cry and cry and she
won't stop crying they start to try and
stop pray now crying
like try and console her which is kind
of bizarre and then for the next couple
days try and look after her oh days and
at one point Raymond just says to Martha
take care of it yeah yeah I thought this
was coming yeah yeah you can imagine
what happens Martha went down to the
basement she ran a small bath in the tub
and then proceeded to drown the
two-year-old reynell killing her and
they then buried reynell and Delphine in
the basement God that's horrible yeah
that is very dark okay so the police
catch them please catch them and stopped
their crime Raymond and Martha just
confessed to everything so Raymond
I at this point
has admitted to killing as many as 20
women 20. yeah
and so this has been going on for well
none of that was proven so he's
confessed but none of it was proven so
we're not entirely sure but that is what
he confessed to Martha maintained that
she only knew of three of the murders so
Delphine rainelle and Janet Michigan
doesn't have the death penalty right so
they confess thinking that they'll be
you know their centers will be reduced
because they're not going to get the
death penalty once the public found out
about what they had done especially once
they found out they had killed a
two-year-old they were extradited back
to New York which had the death penalty
and after a trial lasted 43 days they
were found guilty and sentenced to death
well there you go they were executed by
the electric chair at sing-sing prison
on the same day March 8 1951 and did
they get their meal they did so for her
last meal Martha Beck ordered fried
chicken french fries and a lettuce and
tomato salad and then Raymond Fernandez
ate an onion omelette French fries and a
bar of chocolate finished by smoking a
Cuban cigar
woof
see I'm not sure how I feel about the
onion omelette but I definitely could
get behind this
so he sneaks into uh a house where there
is a young woman sleeping and he
bludgeons her with a metal rod that has
been taken from her bed frame he then uh
a month later
commits his first kill